washington d.c
our zip code is two zero zero zero one
next we take you to the campus of the
american university here in washington
d.c for our coverage of an american
forum titled jfk
cinema as history
the forum was held wednesday evening and
it featured a panel discussion of oliver
stone's controversial film jfk and its
depiction of events surrounding the 1963
assassination of president john f
kennedy in dallas texas
during the next couple of hours you will
meet a number of participants including
national public radio film critic pat
dowell
16 term democratic congressman henry
gonzalez of texas and colonel fletcher
pratty former chief of special
operations for the joint chiefs of staff
founded in 1986 by au's school of
communication the american forum offers
a platform on which some of the nation's
most influential journalists elected
officials and public policy makers
debate the changing issues of the day we
now bring you our coverage of wednesday
night's event
[Music]
okay
all right
[Music]
good evening
i'm sanford unger dean of the school of
communication here at american
university
and i want to welcome this enthusiastic
crowd to the first in our american forum
series for uh
this semester i appreciate that it's
pretty crowded out there and i just hope
everybody can uh
push together a little bit to
accommodate i'm sorry for the discomfort
we would have moved this program to the
bender arena but a basketball game had
already been
postponed and
rescheduled for tonight and so the
bender arena was not available
and our options were were therefore
limited
want to welcome those who are
in the k spiritual life center with us
and also
those who will be seeing this program
when it is broadcast on the cable
satellite public affairs network or
listening to it on national public radio
via the assistance of wamu fm the
american university public radio station
our subject tonight is jfk the movie
cinema as history we thank as usual the
xerox foundation the washington gas
light company cable holdings and the
evelyn y davis foundation for
their generous contributions that have
made the forums possible
our format is this we're going to begin
tonight by showing two brief clips from
the film jfk
and then
start our discussion among our panelists
and we will as customary leave time for
approximately half an hour of questions
from the audience
i want to appeal now in advance to the
members of this large audience that when
it comes time for questions if you'll
come to the microphone in the center
aisle tell us who you are and please try
to give us a brief question so there'll
be plenty of time we're not inviting
speeches from the floor so i'll
appreciate if people could could try to
respect that ground rule
after the program there will be a
reception in the university lounge on
the first floor of mary graydon center
down the quad and if you follow the
crowd if you don't know how to get there
i'm sure you'll have an easy time let me
introduce our panelists before we look
at some film clips pat dowell on my left
is
film critic for national public radio
w-e-t-a-f-m
here in various newspapers and until
recently washingtonian magazine she will
explain that to us later
her articles on film and her reporting
on film has appeared in
many publications including the
washington post baltimore sun american
film and she frequently lectures at
local universities and has served as a
judge at film festivals
to her left is stephen rosenfeld who is
deputy editorial page editor and a
columnist for the washington post
uh steve rosenfeld has worked for the
post since 1959.
he has been
he was a moscow correspondent at one
stage a city reporter and previous to
his
uh to that was an intelligence and
communications officer in the marine
corps between 1953 and 1955.
to his left is fletcher prouty retired
u.s air force colonel who served as an
advisor to oliver stone's movie jfk and
we're told as the model for the film's
character x played by donald sutherland
uh the resemblance is somewhat striking
fletcher pratty served as chief of
special operations for the u.s joint
chiefs of staff during the eisenhower
and kennedy administrations and he's the
author of the secret team a book about
his years in the pentagon and the cia to
my immediate right is congressman henry
gonzalez democrat from the 20th district
of texas
very pleased he could be with us tonight
congressman gonzalez has been in
congress
for 30 years i believe first elected in
1961
he is chairman of the house committee on
banking finance and urban affairs and of
the house subcommittee on housing and
community development in 1976
congressman gonzalez served as the first
chair of the house select committee on
assassinations set up to investigate the
deaths of president kennedy
senator robert kennedy and dr martin
luther king
to his right is john judge who folks
co-founded the committee for an open
archives in november of last year
mr judge is organizing lobbying efforts
to obtain full public access to all
materials relating to the assassination
of president kennedy
his analysis on this subject has
appeared in newsweek and in spy magazine
to his right is dan mulday an
independent journalist who has
specialized in investigations of
organized crime since 1974.
in
his book the hoffa wars dan molday was
the first to
state that former teamsters president
jimmy hoffa and two mafia figures
were involved according to
his version of events and the
assassination of president kennedy
dan mulday has published his articles in
the washington post regarding his
village voice and the nation among other
places we're going to pause now
to
dim the lights and look at two clips
from the film jfk and then start a
conversation
we should be investigating our mafia
leads here in new orleans now i can buy
that a hell of a lot easier than i can
the government
ruby is all mob
knows oswald sets him up
hoffa traffic canty marcelos they hire
some guns to do kennedy and uh the
government doesn't want to open up a
whole can of worms there because it used
a mob to try to get to castro
you know castro being assassinated by
the mob by us it sounds pretty wild to
junk you citizen so
they close the book on jfk
makes perfect sense to me i don't doubt
the involvement bill but at a lower
level
oh come on could the mob change the
parade route bill
or eliminate the protection for the
president could the mob send oswald to
russia and get him back
could the bob get the fbi the cia and
the dallas police to make a mess of the
investigation i mean could the mob get
the wall commission appointed to cover
it up
could the mob wreck the autopsy i mean
could the mob influence the national
media to go to sleep and since when has
the mob used anything but 38 for hits up
close
mob wouldn't have the guts or the power
for something of this magnitude
assassins need payrolls
schedules times orders
this was a military-style ambush from
start to finish so the coup d'etat with
lyndon johnson waiting in the wings
then
the cabinet was out of the country to
get their perceptions out of the way
troops are in the air for possible riot
control the telephones didn't work to
get the wrong stories from spreading if
anything went wrong with the plan
nothing was left to chance he could not
be allowed to escape alive
well i never thought things were the
same after that
vietnam started for real there was an
air of
i don't know
make believe in the pentagon ncaa those
of us who'd been in secret ops since the
beginning knew the warren commission was
fiction
but there was something
something deeper
uglier
i knew alan dulles very well i briefed
him many a time in his house
but for the life of me i still can't
figure out why he was appointed to
investigate kennedy's death the man who
had fired him
dallas by the way was
general wise benefactor
i got out in 64
resigned my commission
i never realized kennedy was so
dangerous to the establishment
is that why
well that's the real question isn't it
why
the how and the who is just
scenery for the public
oswald ruby cuba the mafia
keeps them guessing like some kind of
paula game prevents them from asking the
most important question why
why was kennedy killed
who benefited
who has the power to cover it up
steve rosenfeld you have
written about this film in the
washington post and expressed your
objections to it i wonder if you could
explain those to us now
being sure to use the microphone
terrific drama
at best questionable and worst lousy
docu
that's the heart of my objection
on the film does not distinguish between
the two
you are given the famous medical room
operating room seen in grainy black and
white as though it's a real
scene when one tries to put together the
picture when what one gets is a
excellent picture of the thoughts
of the director of the film
the relationship to history to what i
would call reality
at best unproven
and in fact in my judgment
awful
pat dowell you make your living
commenting on film what is your reaction
to jfk
i thought it was a brilliant film
uh in fact in many ways i think it
really is the american film of 1991
which is the year it came out so we'll
be seeing most people will be seeing it
in 1992 but it's really it's really the
film of the year for americans i think
because
it challenges our ideas of what history
is
i think
you can't prove that anything the film
says is true
because you can't prove anything with a
film i mean
um
when kevin costner is garrison says
towards the end about theoretical
physics that you could prove with
theoretical physics that an elephant
could hang from a cliff with his tail
tied to a daisy my immediate thought was
yes and the other thing that can prove
that is a film
uh but
even though you can't prove the facts
are true
the the important part of the movie to
me and really what makes it valuable to
us
is the fact that it reminds us that we
only know as much of history as we're
told and that that's often not the truth
um
as we're told over and over again an
individual has to
make justice uh it isn't delivered to us
but as for whether the facts the film
states are true that i don't know i have
no problem believing that
a large conspiracy could exist
because uh certainly what we've seen in
the last 20 years suggests that american
military and business interests have
subverted other countries why not ours
so
it seems to me that
what you have to ask yourself is the
larger meaning of it and if you want to
find out if the facts are true you have
to do the digging yourself i understand
incidentally that an annotated script is
going to be published that should help a
little bit
congressman gonzalez you
launched and
supervised
an investigation of the assassinations
in congress
are you comfortable now with the state
of our knowledge about the kennedy
assassination uh well let me clarify
oh i did initiate the first resolution
in february of 1975
but
realizing the constitutional inhibitions
on the congress's power to investigate
i did not call for a whodunit type of
investigation
but rather wanted very desperately to
have the congress evaluate the impact
of violence on a national level over an
eight-year period beginning with the
assassination of john kennedy and then
martin luther king and then robert
kennedy and the attempt on george
wallace
on the basis that every one of these had
an impact on our democratic electoral
processes of our government
but that was diverted i also want to
clarify that i was not the first
chairman
i was the author of the
resolution and ordinarily under the
presidents and customer of the house
that would have been but i wasn't
outgoing speaker carl albert
three weeks before
the end of that congress
decided to push for the adoption of some
resolution
to investigate
john f kennedy and martin luther king's
deaths
so
i wasn't
favorable to the notion of changing the
thrust of the resolution
and so he appointed
a lame duck member of the house as the
first chairman
mr downing of virginia
now this was
september three weeks before the end of
the session
so that we had to reorganize all over
again come january the 3rd 1977
and uh
the um
trouble then started and uh frustrated
i resigned when i was appointed
chairman in january of 77 by speaker tip
o'neill the new speaker
the fact remains that
i realized that
when there's a crisis of this nature
there will always be a tendency to
be uh
hospitable to conspiracy theories i was
in the motorcade i was behind the car
that contained the vice president
and his wife and the u.s senator ralph
yarborough i heard the shots because i
had lowered the window on the left side
where i was riding in the car
and heard them quite distinctly
i have
not formulated any particular
conspiratorial theory
i did end up in the hospital
alone in the corridor with mrs kennedy
the reason i wasn't
in the plane air force one when
lyndon johnson was sworn in was that i
opted to remain there because she was
alone and it also happened through a
chance
that i was standing right outside of the
room
where the president's body
was
laying so
i
haven't formulated any particular
conspiratorial
theory because
i believe that
you have to
abuse evidence
more than a rather vague circumstantial
in order to establish any kind of a
predicate that would lead to some kind
of a formulation
of an action of more than one person
which is a definition of a conspiracy
now i also will conclude by saying that
perhaps i shouldn't be here because i
haven't seen the film jfk
but i have seen some of the first films
of this january
executive action for instance was very
much of this type
conspiracy was implied
it wasn't as forthright as i understand
this picture is but it was understood
that it was a jfk assassination
so
what i do think is troubling is that
the nation and the congress particularly
because it's our national policy-making
body has never evaluated that impact on
our electoral processes which has been
great
it led to the adoption of the 25th
amendment which i consider to be a
dagger pointed at the heart of our
democratic system
now i know that sounds strange but
that's my convictions so that i have no
particular theory to dispute
i really
am not qualified to judge the thrust of
the film other than to say that
um it it doesn't evoke and it can't
we live in a day of television
uh even in the case of the abraham
lincoln assassination 126 years later
we have theories about what really
happened
booth escaped
he ended up in texas
he died in oklahoma
so you're going to have this forever and
a day and what i think is atrocious is
that the committee that ended up in
formulating the conclusion that it was
likely that a conspiracy was to blame
for the death of kennedy wasn't more
specific and then sealed the documents
[Music]
congressman before we move on i i do
want to ask you this you were there
at the assassination i was and are you
are you not
troubled by the fact that you still
really are not satisfied that you know
what happened that day and and and who
was responsible well um
i came up in a way that
i became a newer to random violence
i had been present when
people had been shot just
three yards shot to death
i had faced
a gun being placed in my midriff
and the trigger pulled
president kennedy did not understand
that
if uh
if there was
one there were certainly two occasions
in which i ventured forth to say that
there was a terrible hour of hatred
directed to him
particularly in my area
it's difficult to evoke now after his
death where the image is that he was
very popular and the quint essence of
american youth yes he was with a big
portion of the american population but
there was also a very very strong
environment of hatred terrible hatred
i've never received the hate mail that i
did the first year that i came to the
congress which was 6162
and i couldn't convey that
even within the congress
in the house
some of the leaders spoke terribly about
the president
the other little established fact is
that on that day january
november the 22nd 63 not one
appropriation bill had been approved for
the first time in peacetime
that to me is something you can't evoke
now also today we take for granted the
tremendous security we have we're used
now and in europe to go an airport
getting checked
at the time he died president kennedy
died you could go at midnight on a
sunday to the capitol and walk at random
and nobody would challenge you now that
can't be evoked and i don't think the
film would but we live in a day and time
in which when you have a crisis of this
kind they're difficult to explain
in a day of tv the conspiratorial
feeling is going to be prevalent
one of the latest cases for instance
was mayor berry
how many times did we read in the
newspaper that it was a white conspiracy
against the mayor
we're prone to that in a day of
television in which images
are dramatized they're personalized
uh they're difficult to understand from
an abstract point of view so i think
i've over extended myself
thank you
uh fletcher prouty
you uh
are represented by donald sutherland in
that second film clip that we saw
and i wonder if you can
explain to us
in real life
what it is
you believe
that
donald sutherland in representing you
was was saying at that point i take it
you do believe
that there was a conspiracy
to murder president kennedy
you know
what has happened
since we came out with this film is
really
unbelievable
i don't know what people look for when i
think of the word conspiracy
it's just astounding
if you plan if you make a plan to do
something
that's a normal human
arrangement
but if you add evil to that plan
and there are others with you
that's a conspiracy
now you don't decide that in court you
don't go out and find another murderer
you go out and string up a whole bunch
of things in question history all the
way back to
wherever you want to go the conspiracy
is laying right out in front of us and
don't we recognize it
i got off a plane coming up from the
south pole and i was in christchurch new
zealand
and i heard the british radio come on
and say
president kennedy has been shot
dead
in dallas just that way i'll never
forget the phrasing of it
i was with a congressman
we had all been down
we went up the street see what we could
do to get some more news
and about two a half two to two and a
half hours later
we found a man selling extras on the
street
i bought the paper and i looked at it
at that time i had been a pentagon for
nine years working on special operations
that means clandestine operations in the
military and the agency working together
i'm pretty familiar with this sort of
thing
and on the front of that paper was a
picture of the school book depository
building where the alleged killer had
been
i looked at it windows were open you
know when we protect the president we go
there ahead of time we make sure the
building overhead windows have been
closed by people that are trained to do
that
another thing the thing said
three bursts of automatic weapons
now i don't know congressman whether
that's what you heard or not that's what
the reporter said that's not what the
fbi said the fbi said bing
boom bing from that man on the sixth
floor and that's all there was to it
three bursts of automatic weapon by a
reporter that was on the scene
what bothered me more
not then but later
was the bottom third of that paper
was a whole story of lee harvey oswald
been to russia with the marines at
atsugi and i read that sugi
atsugi was at fari's headquarters the
cia i've been there many times in fact i
was there before the surrender of japan
a couple of days before we're getting
prisoners of war out it's an underground
base
the only marines we take to atsugi
in a military and and cia work
like on the u2 and all that sort of
thing
are the cream of the crop or they don't
get there
while oswald was at atsugi
we st we tried to help a rebellion
against socano in indonesia he was one
of the men picked to go down to the
indonesian campaign he was no dud
don't let anybody kid you
so when i got home i checked that
biography of
oswald pretty interested by the time i
got home eight days later
and i found out that
the police had not even charged oswald
with the crime
by the time that story was in the new
zealand newspaper now i understand how
fast news can go in communication but i
mean who put it all together where did
they get the news of this random 24 year
old
uh even though he did have a
uh unusual history at least we hear that
afterwards before that for the pretty
exemplary history to tell you the truth
i've been at utsugi during the period
when he was there i never met him but i
know the quality of people we use there
well you add these things up
failure to have the military unit there
that provides protection for the
president in any city where he goes i've
gone to mexico city for that purpose
the
failure of the secret service to be
adequately
stationed throughout the city
and this
story written before the police even
knew who the killer was here the writer
of this story
knew all about him before the police did
how many things do the autopsy reports
are a mess
how many things that people need to wake
up that's what oliver stone's trying to
do he wants the american public to know
that since 1963 we've been told a lie
lyndon johnson before he died said and
it's for right over in your library
atlantic monthly july
1973
i've always believed there was a
conspiracy our ex-president lyndon
johnson and he said oswald did not do it
by himself and he said
we have been operating a murder
incorporated
that inc on the end incorporated means a
murder organization
in perpetuity
unfortunately as an individual i can
report to you that during my work in the
pentagon i have been
required to work among that situation
where people have been murdered by
something that we maintain in the 70s
senator church
pulled that information out of the cia
bit by bit
even though there was perjury committed
now you've got to be serious about this
movie it's not a joke people tell us
we've got the history wrong we've got
all this other stuff wrong
i'd like to see anybody in this room or
anywhere else
lay the line of history down that came
from that movie and and tell me that
it's wrong
it might be a
change in how the film was presented
after all it's a movie i mean what what
do we see in them in movies anyway
well i've spoken too long but this is a
serious film it's not a joke
and i can't believe it
when articles appear in the washington
post and call me a flunky in a jcs when
i was
colonel in charge of secret operations a
special excuse me special operation for
nine years
i know what was going on in that
pentagon and i know what's going on in
the white house
and any of you want to know about it
i'll talk with you later
[Music]
dan molday
in the first clip that we saw one of the
assistants to district attorney jim
garrison in new orleans
is advancing a different theory
that it was
a mob killing of
president kennedy and i take it this is
a theory perhaps not in the exact words
of the film but a theory to which you
subscribe well although i credit oliver
stone with
with uh resurrecting the national debate
on this issue i am a little critical of
him because he takes a premise and then
he takes any shred of evidence
regardless of merit regarding regardless
of sources
and then simply uses it in the movie in
order to bulk up his his his basic
premise itself
organized crime
any reasonable definition of organized
crime is that it is conspiracy crime it
is enterprise crime
and in any probe of underworld
activities there are bottom up
investigations our investigations
concentrate in this particular case on
specific evidence
working from the bottom up
we are clearly aware of the cia mafia
plots to assassinate fidel castro
we are clearly aware and the evidence is
clear that there are wire tasks where
mafia guys
were threatening to kill the president
united states we have interviews with ed
parton the key government witness
against jimmy hoffman his jury tampering
trial in chattanooga that jimmy hoffa
was planning to kill bobby kennedy in
september of 1962
and that in that same month we have
interviews with eddie becker
who
who was talking to carlos marcelo who
said we are not going to kill bobby
kennedy as hoffa wants to do we're going
to kill the president united states
we have interviews with jose aleman who
was talking to santos trafficking in
that same month in september of 1962
after aft when traffic connie said that
the president is going to be hit
and that hoffa had made the contract on
the president's life
we know that lee harvey oswald was
raised by a guy by the name of charlie
dutsmarat who was running carlos marcelo
the mafia boss of new orleans bookmaking
operations
we know that david ferry was a personal
associate and aide to carlos marcelo who
was in court with him at the moment of
the president's assassination
we note we have jack ruby's telephone
records which show
calls to and from ruby from a variety of
associates of jimmy hoffa carlos
marcello and santos traffic connie
during the days and weeks prior to the
murder
we know that jim garrison's probe was a
deflection away from marcelo and the mob
because
of garrison's own complicity with
marcelo in new orleans
we know that during the brylab
investigations there are three sealed
tapes which the new york times reported
today
in which carlos marcelo made veiled
admissions that he was directly involved
and responsible for the president's
murder
now last week we have frank regano the
attorney for both jimmy hoffa and santos
trophicani who has flat out said that it
was jimmy hoffa santos trophicani and
carlos marcello who arranged and
executed the assassination of the
president united states and that he
wishes to testify under oath before the
appropriate congressional committee in
order to get the truth out after all of
these years what we are suggesting is
let's get rigano before a committee
let's get him deposed
let's get what his story is and let the
evidence go wherever it goes oliver
stone speaks in theories and premises
the people who are advocating that
organized crime should be the principal
target investigation are speaking from
facts and specific credible evidence
john judge
[Applause]
you favor opening the archives i wonder
whether you have any
preliminary
hypotheses about what would be found
there if the archives were opened
i think more important than what
specifically remains in the archives
norman mailer compared it to a
to a mercedes-benz that's been left i
think he set up in harlem for 20 years
in terms of what we might find but we do
have lists of what was put in so we can
at least compare them to what comes out
but i think what's more important is the
principle that this is public
information and it belongs to us the
people of the united states and not to
any secret government or intelligence
network or any president or any congress
who were merely hired by us to do our
bidding anyway
you know
[Applause]
thomas jefferson said that given a
choice between a government with no
newspaper and a newspaper with no
government he'd always choose the latter
of course he never had a chance to read
the washington post or the new york
times but
[Applause]
[Music]
the principle he was getting at is that
democracy doesn't work unless the people
are educated and he said that the final
repository the ultimate repository of
all knowledge must rest in the people
and that there's no one else who's good
enough or smart enough to invest that
control in in our truly democratic
society
and we call
for a full opening of the files not
dribbled out through pre-censorship like
freedom of information act documents
with pieces missing not to selected
historians or medical experts not to a
special prosecutor or yet another
congressional investigation but to the
people
themselves and much of this that we know
about the kennedy case
and the evidence of conspiracy comes
from the hard work of independent
individual investigators whose names
are not mentioned in large part in the
film
may brussel penn jones sylvia maher
holcomb heston paris lamonde
and that's only a few the current
researchers
robert grodin
and
and and the and philip melinson are
still continuing to follow the evidence
when that material comes out they will
be extra little pieces in the jigsaw
puzzle in the mosaic but we've had
enough out in these many years to solve
the case
there's enough of the picture visible in
the record and in the historical view
that we've had in order to get at the
bottom of it
so i don't see the files ultimately as
holding so much of a smoking gun
as merely telling us one more time what
the government did or didn't find out
about the case i would like to support
the film i think that out outside of the
films done by civil war buffs who try to
get every uniform and every rifle right
that oliver stone has done the most
historically accurate work on the
kennedy assassination to date the reason
it struck a nerve is that this is the
hidden secret in the american psyche
since that day november 22nd 63 the
american public has known and in fact i
would contend has been told over and
over that there was a conspiracy to kill
the president states that the people who
did it got away with it and that we
can't touch them
and i think that's a lot in large part
why so few people vote nowadays but
stone has gone into that darkness and
shown a light and looked at things and i
think the conclusion of his film is
right i think from my own work i read
the 26 vimes of the warren commission
you know alan dulles when he was asked
about releasing the evidence by hal
boggs said go ahead and print it nobody
will read it anyway and unfortunately
especially now in a post-literate
generation stone's film is about the
only thing that will reach youth there
are a few of us who read still but as
you well know the fbi is trying to get
our name from the library
so this has crossed over the line and
it's why it's so disturbing but let me
tell you two stories to end that
convinced me that this was not only a
conspiracy but a conspiracy well beyond
the capability of any mafia goon of any
cia schlepper of any renegade element in
the us intelligence of any oilmen with a
beef these are the layers of the onion
that were planted at the beginning so
we'd never see the core my mother worked
for 20 25 or 30 years altogether but 25
years for the deputy chief of staff and
the personnel office of the u.s army
directly under the joint chiefs of staff
she was the highest paid woman employee
of the pentagon she was five levels
above top security
i mentioned to fletcher proudly the
other day i work from the bottom up and
he works in the top down and we met at
the joint chiefs
my mother's job was to project overall
national draft call figures five years
in advance she had to project an annual
national selective service call that was
right within a hundred people either way
five years ahead
she knew from those projections and from
the information she got that they were
withdrawing from vietnam and if you want
to get hold of the papers that prove
prouty's point i just got this today at
the government printing office foreign
relations in the united states
61-63 the state department papers are
released in volume 4 of the vietnam
series this is august to december 1963
and the security memoranda are in there
to talk about kennedy's plan it's been
backed up by arthur schlesinger and more
recently yesterday i believe or the day
before in the new york times by roger
hillsman he was pulling out my mother
knew that because she had to project
those kind of figures i asked her after
she retired when did they tell you they
would escalate in vietnam because she
had to be among the first to know she
said late november of 63. i said the
last week in november she said yes the
monday following the assassination i
said was this a few more advisers a
change in policy she said i couldn't
believe the figures i took them back to
the joint chiefs and what must have been
the first protest by the civilian
community of the war in vietnam and said
these can't be right
and they said you'll use them they told
her november 25 1963 that the war in
vietnam would last for 10 years and the
57 000 americans would die and to figure
that in
i also talked to sac bomber pilots
strategic air command bomber pilots who
have the responsibility of nuclear and
emergency response who are in the air on
regular shifts 24 hours a day these were
in the air over wright-patterson air
force base when they heard the news that
kennedy had been shot they ran to open
lockers that contain a cryptograph code
book that allows them to tell whether
the president is calling them and to
take orders that go all the way out to
fail-safe and nuclear war there was not
a pilot in the air that hour over right
pad anyway and i would contend this is
the case everywhere else no reason to
isolate it that had a code book in that
locker we know from pierre salinger's
book that there was no code book aboard
air force two bringing the entire
cabinet back from important meetings
that changed the course in vietnam in
the next few days
they were in the air and had no way to
communicate with the white house or the
president there is nobody that can touch
those books besides the joint chiefs of
staff in the highest levels of defense
intelligence and at every level of my
work the office of navy intelligence is
who rears its head on the mechanic level
the defense industrial security command
these are this is the background of
oswald and guy bannister and jack ruby
when we go into them and whatever is in
the record will merely back that up the
physical evidence is already in front of
us so we know that one lone nut with an
old gun that lost the war for the
italians in world war ii
which couldn't even shoot a bullet to
line up with its own scope didn't do the
damage in dallas but kennedy wasn't all
that was killed that day democracy died
[Music]
i want to come back around to something
that you said pat and i want to give
steve rosenfeld a chance to respond to
some of these points but
uh
you said that
you're not sure it matters
how accurate the film is how accurate
the history is and other people are
saying the history is exactly accurate
what i'm what i'm wondering is whether
have we really reached a point where
history the history we can
all
have some confidence in
is going to be
determined
our most believable
version of history will be determined at
the box office or by people by people
you know voting with their feet about
which theory they believe well
you know with all due respect to the
panelists who all have marshaled an
enormous number of facts
the fact is that you listening out there
and i myself because i'm not a
conspiracy buff and i haven't perused
all the literature you can't tell from
listening to any of us what the facts of
the case are
just as you can't tell from hearing from
seeing oliver stone's movie i mean we
can say whatever we want but you don't
know that it's so just because we say it
you have to go out and find it out to
find out whether it's true
i think the film has has pushed a button
because
it really goes to something deeper than
simply
a 28 or 29 year old murder
i i think people do want to know who
killed kennedy and why but i think that
the reason that that is such a burning
issue
is to some extent what john judge said
that in fact i don't think it's so much
that democracy died that day because i'm
not so sure democracy was hail and hardy
before that day
but
i think i think america has begun to
catch on to what happens in its
government and in the last 20 years
we've been catching on more and more and
people are are sick at heart about it i
uh the film speaks to that and what the
film does
in
well it's a little like something that
kevin costner says at one point in the
movie you know he's reading the books
garrison is when he's first getting
interested in the case and he's saying
it's all here but it's all broken up
into all these little pieces and you
can't tell what's going on and what the
film does it brings all those pieces
into one place and shows you that they
are indeed fragments of a whole lot of
different realities uh that's why you
have all those different kinds of film
stockings all those different frame
sizes
he really is presenting you with this
huge banquet of evidence that
he thinks all stacks up a certain way
but he leaves you enough room to agree
or disagree i for instance uh have
trouble believing that kennedy was as
was as dangerous to the establishment
that's what we saw in the clip was
kennedy i didn't know kennedy was that
dangerous to the establishment garrison
says or stone in this case because
that's who the conversation was with
really and my thinking is well yeah i
thought kennedy was the establishment um
and and so
you know i think what's going on here is
people are grappling with something else
that the film crystallizes for us rather
than just the case of this 28 year old
murder and it really goes to the press
and the policy makers and that's why
they've gained up on the film um
and i can give you a personal example of
this i have been the washingtonians film
critic the washingtonian magazine here
in washington for ten years but last
friday i resigned because the editor of
that magazine jack limpert spiked my 100
word review i write thumbnail reviews
for the washingtonian he spiked my
review of jfk
which in magazine parlance means that he
cut it from the february column that it
was going into that i write and
we had an exchange of letters about it
and i told him i couldn't continue and
he he told me that the reason he cut it
was because it seemed to him that
stone's film went to the heart of what
kind of city this is
in other words
in other words
there there are a lot of people and most
of them have access to print
and to broadcasting uh channels who
believe that this is really an insult to
the people that they report on and
consort with most of the time in other
words to the policy makers
rather than those film is an insult i
think so i think that explains a lot of
the really vehement reaction to it yours
was actually fairly mild i thought in
your account you were pretty pretty fair
i mean you didn't foam at the mouth it
seemed to me and i've seen some articles
where people phoned at the mouth
actually your paper has run somewhere
people thumbed at the mouth about it and
uh it seems to me that that's what's
going on here with the press attacking
the film and uh
that that in fact and it's mostly the
editorial press the op-ed press because
critics
have either loved it or hated it but
most of them have loved it actually uh
the post critics raved about it time and
newsweek critics raved about it even
though uh the news weeklies managed to
get onto their cover uh uh tag lines uh
they managed to print titles across
their cover that suggested that the
movie was a distortion pardon me a
distortion of history even though their
critics said they thought it was a
really quite
a brilliant movie i guess those become
two separate questions
whether it's a brilliant movie and
whether it's good history
well yes and no i i think they're
related i don't think they're entirely
unrelated excuse me sandy can we
interact among the panelists absolutely
by all means and but i i was coming to
steve rosenfeld but go ahead dan well i
just simply want to say when you buy a
book
uh you know whether it's fiction or
non-fiction uh when you go to see a
movie you just don't know and i'm stone
labels this movie as being dependent on
two books garrisons and another fellow
what's his name mars
and uh and he attempts to portray it as
non-fiction and this is
excuse me
um this is an interpretation he he
portrays this as being an interpretation
of a true story but he's sort of blurred
the distinction and i also think that
that's one reason why stone's getting a
lot of grief right now but he's also
getting a lot of grief because he has
used jim garrison as his motif for this
movie himself once again jim garrison
the evidence is clear
was in the pocket of the new orleans
crime syndicate that is never portrayed
in the film itself the one thing that
lee harvey oswald jack ruby david ferry
and jim garrison had in common was their
connection to the marcelo crime
organization once again marcelo's
investigation and has been repeatedly
proven was a deflection away from the
investigation of the mafia where the
most credible evidence currently exists
that's the reason why
why oliver stone is taking as much grief
as he's taken because the movie simply
lacks
integrity
steve rosenfeld uh
you've been credited for not foaming at
the mouth
uh
can
what is what is your feeling about
there is a sense that somehow
the establishment the media
establishment
or some figures in it are ganging up on
this movie are
and this is what what pat dowell is
saying too
now but i don't think it's a conspiracy
[Laughter]
dan molday says it's because
it's for other reasons but how do you
feel about that journalists have only
one basis at which they can approach
the public and that is that what they're
saying is as close to the facts as they
can manage doesn't mean they get all the
facts or all the facts right every day
but certainly the pursuit of the fact
is the only reason for being a
journalist
along comes a movie producer who as pat
dowell says gives us what she calls
fragments of realities and a banquet of
evidence
and yet the field is a farago if i may
use such a word
of
truth and untruths of the products of
the of some realistic dominant uh
documentation and the products
of a fevered imagination
when i
realized i was going to have the
privilege of hearing colonel prouty
tonight i said aha this will be my
chance to see
what really was going on in oliver
stone's mind as he made this film
because surely colonel prouty being
familiar with the material
would have
another view of it because i couldn't
understand how anyone in the film donald
sutherland
who was spinning together this mad web
of circumstance i didn't think that
it had any coherence at all
dramatic conspiracy coherence perhaps
but factual coherence no
instead i'm disappointed colonel if i
may say so
you arrive at the town of new zealand
and see a newspaper article and you say
huh that's got a lot of detail in it and
you give us some other extremely
interesting
factoids little small facts unrelated to
big
large facts
about
your passage through
new zealand and your passage through the
events leading up to this story
who among us would like to be convicted
of a crime on the basis of the sort of
evidence
that you sir presented you slept through
what i saw didn't you
i said a lot more than that
i talked about nine years in the
pentagon did you hear that did you hear
anything about nine years in the
pentagon any at all i was one day in new
zealand speak under the machine please
are you listening
you'll have to speak in the microphone
or it's wasted okay well i'll speak in
the microphone but
he slept through when i was talking
about my nine years in the pentagon but
he didn't sleep through that one or two
days in new zealand now come on wake up
that's a trouble with your paper
when when
when one of the finest writers in the
new york times tom wicker
said there's no reasonable historian
[Music]
that would find any basis for the fact
that kennedy was making plans
not to build in vietnam and actually to
get out of vietnam with american troops
and he said no basis for that that book
that john just held up
contains more than 50 meetings that my
own boss went to general krulak and the
jcs
with kennedy maxwell taylor rusk and
mcnamara building those plans from
august of 63
until he was killed well until october
when the
national security act of memorandum
number 263 was written
[Music]
and and good old tom wicker working like
matt up there
has never noticed that
or anything what on earth are they
trying to tell us you know what this
means free the files it's a euphemism
free the press
congressman gonzalez
uh
how do you think
this is going to evolve as an
understanding of history
will we arrive in
any reasonable period of time at
what we might regard as the truth about
the assassination
well as i said earlier
when these events occur
it's very difficult for the
uh
mind
to accept what seems to be unexplainable
and unacceptable
so
we will have in this day and time
given
our television age
more
conspiracy
settings
than perhaps before
nevertheless your question i think is
very pertinent and i think that
one shouldn't be angry at the the fact
that the movie was manufactured
that stone has
again pricked the conscience the dormant
conscience as
mr judge said the psyche
because it is something that
has troubled
the american conscience consistently
look this is 30 years later
the young students here today
weren't even living at the time of
president kennedy test yet
they have continued
a
strong
an enduring interest in ascertaining
an answer to some of the questions that
have naturally arisen because the
circumstances surrounding that
assassination
are bound to give rise to questions the
fact that
there's very little understanding about
the limitations
in our branch of the government with
respect to
direct investigations
as to who done it uh also complicates
the problem
because the executive branch did
appoint the commission known as a warren
commission
the thing there was that you cannot
recall the pressure under which that
commission was acting they were under
the gun to issue a report
before the year was up
and they did
the one good thing of the warren
commission like the good thing that
comes out of these movies is
that it presents
it acted like a
vacuum cleaner
and it amassed 26 volumes
of documented evidence
for instance
there's nothing in the proceedings of
the commission that indicate they
evaluated the full role of ruby
yet in the documentation you'll find
a lot of documentation showing ruby's
background
as a professional hitman in chicago
that all has implications but what i'm
saying is
that
the
impact
on our electoral and democratic
processes has been great and detrimental
and there i think the congress fell down
on its job
because of its aborted attempt
to do the extra constitutional thing
that it has no power to do
and that is to act as if it were an
executive branch investigating committee
as if it was a special cia or fbi which
it can't be
uh and and it won't ever be
but
i do think that um
the movie if anything and as i said
before i qualify my opinion because i
haven't seen it but i think that
it does serve a purpose
in reminding us that uh there is a
continuing responsibility to understand
that period of violence
we had
eight years
of national violence
on a level that we had not experienced
before
and it had an impact on our governmental
processes
that we are reacting to today
the era of secrecy
i wasn't aware that the house committee
had sealed documents it's abhorrent to
my concept of a
congressional committee's action excuse
me congressman how do you how do you
handle in your in your career how do you
handle confidential witnesses and
libelous information do you release all
that information that's basically what's
in the house select committee on
assassination with their what's in the
boxes right now it's about to be
released would you give out confidential
source information or libelous
information
well in what instances did the committee
entertain
in camera or in executive session any
witnesses where the testimony was not
printed forth
i don't know of any
i've been in political elective office
for
thirty uh
38 years seven months
and i'll tell you the truth i haven't
seen one instance yet
in which secrecy
was ever justified
where what we were told in executive
session the banking committee
six seven years ago
the regulator saying oh well we we can't
tell you the true state of some 300
institutions because it's very delicate
when we met in executive session
we didn't know anymore any less
than before
when the house resolved itself into an
executive session in 1982
on the basis that we were going to be
briefed by the cia on the nicaraguan
situation
where president reagan had said that the
city of harlingen texas was in a direct
path of invasion from the contras
now how do you evoke that today
i didn't go to that executive session
i have voted against every vote to
convert the committee
uh
banking committee into executive session
nevertheless under the rules it is
provided for now you ask a question that
would be more pertinent to the armed
services committee
where you might have sensitive national
defense
information that's understandable but in
a case like this
i don't know
what witness
is going to be damaged
by unfounded rumors
and who's going to be the judge a
handful in the congress to say
well this is the information we think is
too dangerous to put out so we'll seal
it or the people
or those that are charged or have
assumed the responsibility of following
through
on evaluating the workings of that
committee
we have had for ages in the history of
the house and the senate tension between
the executive branch and the congress
about
the providing of information and
document from the president or the
executive branch
and the president exercised an executive
privilege
now here we are doing the same thing in
this case i think that's abhorrent and
that's the reason that the only reason
i'm back is that i'm introducing the
resolution to release
those sealed documents and that's all
i'm not asking that we're going to form
another committee
because i've seen that the congress has
fallen down on that job i'm going to ask
people with questions to come to the
microphone center aisle in just a moment
but before we get to those i just want
to
and and steve rosenfeld it may be unfair
to turn to you for this question but
there seems to be
the warren commission seems to be
whatever anybody believes
whatever anyone thinks or accepts it
seems not to be the version
advanced by the warren commission and i
wonder it you know in in your
view and your understanding is there
anyone left who defends the warren
commission
and and i my second question to you is
are you opposed to opening up these
files into to uh having this material
looked at by a broad public now
there are people who defend the warren
commission
one of course is uh david beal and the
council gerald ford who was then a
member of the commission also defends it
but i would say otherwise the circle is
exceedingly small and narrow
i think the
consensus view which i certainly accept
is that it was a rush job designed
not so much to get the final answer to
this difficult question as to settle
down a nation thought to be struggling
in a great
trauma
the uh
warren commission report has not stood
the test of time well and that in in its
failure
which i think is a fair word lies the
soil in which the various
conspiracy theories have arisen
all right d do you believe uh desirable
purpose would be served by
opening up all these files some of them
seem to have sealed
for a long time chairman gonzalez i
think is
well known in the congress for believing
in open government and i i certainly
support what he says dan mulday puts a
little asterisk on there material having
to do with uh
personal questions unrelated to the
substance of the inquiry or libelous
material
a
bargain was made with the providers of
evidence and i think that has to be kept
but unquestionably the
our all of our confidence would be
served if that information would be
revealed to the public
it interests me
that
people on different sides of this
question
mr judge and myself
both i think of course mr judge is a
leader in the effort to open the files
he doesn't think that the
public's view or at least his own view
if i understood him correctly is going
to change much on the basis of what
comes out
and dan mulday coming from another point
of view suggests the same thing
so i think that the release of the
information is necessary but whether
it's going to resolve
the type of argument we continue to have
over the question i'm not at all sure
excuse me may i say something
i think one of the reasons why the
warren commission the documents we don't
hold a great deal of hope for that is
because the fbi was the lead
investigative agency in the warren
commission uh investigation j edgar
hoover had basically denied the fact
that organized crime had existed for
years
to all intents and purposes he didn't
have the bureaucracy in place within the
bureau to handle organized crime
investigations and secondly alan dulles
who was the uh was the creator of the
cia mafia plot to assassinate fidel
castro never brought these plots up
before the commission itself it's
difficult for me to believe that had the
cia mafia applause to assassinate finale
cash have been brought up before the
warrant commission that that would not
have created a whole new avenue of
investigation for the commission itself
dan in a sense the theory that you
support that you believe in
uh is dealt a setback by this film
the the certainly there appear to be uh
this is not by any means a random sample
of people who've turned out tonight
for this forum but they're they're
appearing
this film seems to have evoked a very
positive response from a lot of people
and particularly young people
how do you
go about challenging its view with your
view
with the evidence as i stated earlier in
the program the evidence is clear about
this i i don't preclude other people
being involved in this thing but right
now we have adequate evidence enough i
believe to haul into court
i think that the situation is one in
which we have to evaluate the evidence
we have a witness who has now confessed
to being a principle in all of this he
is willing to testify on earth before
congress i think that all of us should
support his right to testify before
congress and then follow the evidence
wherever it goes if it goes into mr
prouty's uh
vietnam scenario fine if it goes into
john judge and all of the all of the
things he believes fine i just think
that the investigation has to start
someplace those of us who've
investigated organized crimes
involvement in all of this have put
together a road map for this and i think
it's simply a matter of following this
credible evidence that has already been
established and who should do it i think
pat dell might say if you want to get
the theory well accepted well that's the
thing that's really troubling right now
we have frank organo who said he's
willing to testify and willing to make a
statement the justice department has not
grabbed him yet had i been the director
of the fbi would be down there sealing
him up no congressional committee has
grabbed him yet to get his deposition so
we've been trying to negotiate with the
permanent subcommittee on investigations
of the united states senate to at least
take his deposition in executive session
before he gets clipped
which i think is a real danger remember
johnny roselli remember sam g and khanna
before they had a chance to tell their
story about this matter they were
whacked out uh in very horrible ways and
i don't want to see this happening to
frank organa i was talking to frank
today and frank is terrified right now
because nobody is coming to him to take
his deposition
chances are well i'm sorry go ahead i
was gonna say chances are if you get the
congress involved you will have a movie
about it we've had several movies from
congress this year and last year and and
look what happens when we do
uh uh because you can you can see the
facts presented in a sort of a way in a
congressional hearing and what happens
is that uh people
have entirely different opinions than
about
what they've seen and what those facts
constitute and who those people were
that they saw on television uh you know
spilling their guts if you will and
uh it seems to me that
you still come back to the problem that
uh you open the files you write a book
somebody else writes a book
it's still a question really of
someone's interpretation well who's
probably oliver stone don't you think if
this film actually does well there could
be a sequel right you know if they open
the files
um but um
rfk
r yes that's right rfk and then ml okay
oliver stone would do it
there's an important point carson
gonzalez
well it's an important point here on
this question uh who's gonna investigate
the committee in its final report
came to the conclusion that it was most
probable
that there was a conspiracy involved in
the death of president kennedy
then
it said we recommend
that this matter be
investigated by the fbi and the justice
department
now the committee never followed through
and it's for i don't know
as far as i know the fbi never
acted on the recommendation of the
committee
so
you know
it's it's very interesting to note
that even though the warren commission
yes did divert personnel from the
fbi ncia
to work in its fact-gathering efforts
that here is a committee saying well we
have reason to believe this was a
conspiracy but
we don't know exactly how
but we now
recommend
as one of our fundamental
recommendations
that the justice department and the fbi
pick up on this and follow through on an
adequate and exhaustive investigation
[Music]
can i ask i'm sorry you're
you won't be picked up by c-span and i
think the viewers are entitled to see
that so i'll ask you to come to the
microphone please and i'll call on you
in just a moment
well i'm i'm sorry i'm not going to
permit people to shout from the audience
because it's not going to get us
anywhere
so if you want to shout go outside if
you want to communicate come to the
microphone the point she was making was
i didn't hear the last remark the point
she was making was that uh it it came
public that gerald ford was reporting
directly
to the fbi and jagger hoover about the
internal workings of the committee and
hoover had reason to to concern himself
uh
i think i think that
dan mulder mentioned the deaths of uh
rosalie and some of the mobsters
which i felt didn't fit the classic
pattern of mob deaths anyway but
uh but in fact cia hits especially
giancana
death at that time who had employed ruby
in chicago in the 50s and in fact when i
went into the chicago rackets commission
uh
that when conor mcgregor
that's new evidence
what's your evidence on that well well
they they had called him from the waste
handlers union in chicago to testify and
he refused to go to the committee i
think that was in 1939 1940. i mean
correct
no you're right it's the third i'm sorry
but
uh there there were um
there were later invest investigations
involved robert kennedy is this i'm
talking about
in the in in these in these racket
investigations and they attempted to
call giancana and he refused and was was
taken in uh
actually into custody for refusing and
then they attempted to take his
um
his second in command
uh jacob rubenstein in chicago and i
found a letter in the in the in the
records
from the white house from richard nixon
saying don't subpoena this individual
and there was evidence that that ruby
himself had in that earlier period
worked with the fbi
and much of ruby's connections to both
the fbi and military intelligence have
been drawn out by some of the the
researchers but a more important death i
think was that of william sullivan
a person who headed up division five of
the fbi the domestic operation division
who came in with carthage deloach in the
40s from the office of naval
intelligence promising hoover that
they'd protect his turf from the cia
uh and eventually i believe compromised
the the workings of the of the fbi to to
a large degree and this navy
intelligence threat is the one that i
find most significant in the background
of oswald was a navy intelligence
operative and guy bannister the person
who's depicted new orleans in the film
oswald didn't have mafia jobs he had
intelligence jobs from matsugi to uh to
the to the job he had in new orleans at
the william riley coffee canning company
the president of that company was the
main financial angel for e howard hunt's
cuban democratic revolutionary front
down there in new orleans and uh he had
a job as an oiler and they said he could
go out excuse me john you're saying that
that oswald was created essentially to
do this job i mean
he defected to the soviet union in 1959
john kennedy wasn't even president then
that's right no he doesn't have to be
created to do the job dan what i'm
saying is he's got a history even the
defection itself is clearly phony and
set up by navy intelligence he gets his
discharge because a box dropped in his
mother's nose nine months before and the
letter documenting it arrives four days
after he gets the hardship you try it in
the marines and uh you know he he was
positioned he moved on orders but these
were intelligence orders and at jagger
charles stovall he had had to have navy
security clearance to work in that shop
because they looked at all the
photographs that the navy did from their
satellites and in fact it was from that
shop when he was working there that the
pictures in 61 went to john kennedy with
the missiles in cuba that led to the
cuban missile crisis and so there's much
more of a background of ties to
intelligence it's not that the mob
couldn't have been involved but the mob
in terms of the real power in this
country as far as i'm concerned are
nothing but shoeshine boys aaron boys
for the for the people that really
control and pull the strings and they
don't need the mob they don't need
somebody who can blackmail them later
and the mob aren't the only ones that
know how to shoot a gun
pat dell and then we're going to go to
questions from the audience
you know it's really fascinating to to
hear all these things i have to say i
said before i'm not i'm not in a
assassination buff i was in dallas when
jfk was killed i i lived there i grew up
there and i was in high school but
that's about as close as i've come to
the whole thing
uh besides this movie
well
but you know in listening to all this i
keep coming back to this you know if
they open the files
and i'd really like to be around to see
that it's i still think it's probably
not going to give us the smoking gun we
want the fact is that no matter how many
facts we get out here we're still
dealing with people's interpretations of
those facts and how those facts are put
together i mean that's what non-fiction
uh is you know that's what history is
when you read a nonfiction book you're
really reading someone's interpretation
someone's opinion about what the facts
are and mean
and what i hope comes out from this film
and its greatest service i really
i can live with not ever really knowing
to a legal certainty
who killed kennedy and why but but i
hope that what comes out of this movie
is that it it stimulates us
that it enrages us enough to deal with
the government that we have now rather
than the conspiracy we had then
[Music]
on that note if there are questions will
you come to the microphone and tell us
who you are
good evening
good evening my name is jeff bloom a
graduate student in journalism and
public affairs here at the american
university i'd like to ask any of the
panelists
a fundamental question that pat dowell
had had alluded to
and that is
supposing the files were open supposing
all the evidence kernel priority
presented some rodeo presented everybody
presented was out for consumption
this raises the question of what is
history what is fact
what would it do to our national fiber
and how would we act on it and will we
be able to believe anything anymore not
just about government but about each
other
i mean
it wouldn't be chaos
and that's what i want that's what i
want to throw out uh to anybody and that
shakes out a fundamental thing of what
do we stand on if anything
thank you jeff well i do think that's
what makes the movie so convulsive
uh for us is that it suggests that no we
can't believe anything and that's a very
uncertain obviously place to be
what's not so clear and what stone
doesn't really have to anything more to
say to us you know to help us as an
artist is when at the end when kevin
koffner costner lifts his eyes to the
camera and says it's up to you it's not
so clear that we're up to it but
you know i mean that really is
that really is what's left to us i think
uh any any other thoughts on that what
can we believe colonel proudly what can
we believe
that's an interesting discussion
i'm absolutely astounded by the
development of it
whenever you run
a clandestine operation
you run two things at the same time
you prepare the team for the hit and you
keep it so small there's nobody to
spread it all around
and across the hall is a big staff
working on what we call special plans
i've got a book from the pentagon here
and i can show you
they're preparing the cover story
the cover story is what they want people
to believe and to talk about and to
argue about and everything that's what
the warren commission report is it's the
cover story
can't we understand what's the matter
with us
if somebody took money about out of our
bank account we'd figure it out quicker
than this
you know
and this is regular when i when i came
into the pentagon in 1955 and we started
this work across the hall from me i was
special operations clandestine operation
was a cover story office
when it went down to the joint chiefs of
staff to set up the same machinery for
all services in the military
what was the whole
office across me special plans setting
up cover story when two or three
mechanics
hit men from murder incorporated
kill kennedy and dallas
the rest of the whole story is a cover
story you ever hear the mongoose program
cost 50 million dollars a year to set it
up and provide these kind of people now
the camp for these people is not in the
united states we wouldn't do that
there was a major general working with
me in the defense department he came
back one day from the white house
he said proudly go get me my retirement
papers right now
i said what's the matter he said those
bastards in the white house are going to
kill that man
he said he's one of the finest
anti-communist leaders we've been
working with they're going to kill him
and they did the next day they
assassinated the leader of the country
these things happen don't we know what's
going on
well i think people do recognize that
the warren commission is a cover story
our problem now is that everything is a
cover story you know who elected ronald
reagan how did george bush get to be
president how did the hostages get free
you know how did uh iran
you know how how do our our allies shift
from day to day depending on uh you know
who we're running guns to everything's a
cover story on the nightly news now well
that gives you where did my bank go you
know where did what snl failed why can't
i buy a decent airline ticket
everything's a cover story now that's
our problem excuse me excuse me
[Music]
excuse me can i address the cover story
issue i want to ask you go ahead dan mr
proud i'm just out of wild curiosity
you're talking about the cover story in
1979 the house select committee on
assassinations said that there was a
probable conspiracy in the john kennedy
murder and that it was probably arranged
by organized crime are you saying that
lewis stokes and robert blakey the chief
counsel of the committee were putting
together a cover story for the american
public
read it
do you believe all you're saying these
men of impeccable credentials and
reputation have put out nothing more
than a cover story to the american
public
the hardest work is to prepare the cover
story and and look how good it is it
would prepare it was it was published in
26 volumes you know the warrant
commission now 26 volumes
1964 came became public
and those 26 volumes
have been living up to today
we still have to argue whether it's true
or not
and it is being perfected from day to
day because it keeps up with what's
happening there's a there's a power so
now lewis stokes and robert blakey and
the members of the committee are now
part of your your conspiracy then is
that basically what you're saying that
they are now a part of this cover story
because that'll tell if you answer that
yes that's going to tell me a lot about
everything else you've been saying about
this
for instance how did it happen
that the first writers to find fault
with oliver stone's film before he had
put it in the theater before he had
finished the script they worked on the
first
copy of the script before they even
waited for the seventh copy of the
script
how did it happen that the people that
wrote that generally write what they
call a national security column or
something like that and all of a sudden
they became movie critics before the
movie was even in a theater
i've been kidding ourselves
how many times do we have to say
a george lardner that i used to work
with when i was in the pentagon is
writing about this film what was it two
months three months before it came out
a pack of lies is what he wrote
now
the lord's life is not dumb
[Music]
where does the power come from that
requires a man like that with a great
record
to do something like that so you're
saying george largest part of the
covenant where does the power come from
to make a man where does the power come
from to make a man like earl warren a
chief justice united states signed his
name to the warren commission report
colonel prouty
i used to work with george lardner steve
rosenfeld still does and he's not here
tonight to defend himself we asked him
to be and he he chose not to be
on this panel but i
i
i i don't know that we want to
accept as fact that george lartner has
written a pack of lies
his article not george i've known george
for years he called me before i write
the story and he wanted to know if i had
any information on nsam 263 because he
heard it was going to be in the movie
and he wanted to know about it that
thing has been
available in books since 1963 and he
wanted to know something about the point
is that george largner does not write
about national security not that he does
write about national security but that
he doesn't and that's why he called you
to ask you about that document if he
wrote about national security he
wouldn't have needed to call you and
then in place of that
the article that he wrote is just loaded
with things that are not true
now why did he do that
he's part of the cover story too are you
saying he's part of the cover story too
then i mean you've just defamed three
people here louis stokes
robert blakey the chief counsel of the
assassinations committee george lardner
one of the finest reporters in the
country and you're saying they are all
now part of this cover story which is
consistent with what you were saying in
the movie the mr x thing in the movie
that all of these people are part of
this grand cover-up and all of these
people were part of this conspiracy
against the president united states i
view this as being demagoguery of the
worst degree and i think that's what
you're trying to portray here you guys
are grabbing at everything taking the
big pretext
and then coming down and taking any
shred of evidence
regardless of the it's lack of merit
it's sourcing and you're applying it to
this ridiculous conspiracy theory
that the government of the united states
arranged and executed executed the
murder of the president well you might
have been out of town when the when the
post published an article by
ex-president gerald ford and david bill
on the warren commission report in which
they hit me very hard with an untrue
statement
the post was kind enough to print my
reply
that was the true report jerry ford and
bellin told an untruth
now that i don't think jerry ford
tells untruth maybe on the golf course
once in a while
or that david bellunda the lawyer out in
des moines
but in the case of the movie put out by
oliver stone
they did
what's the compulsion why did they do
that because the minute i wrote back to
the post they printed my letter and
corrected the untruth the same with tom
wicker times printed my letter
i mean i'll take you up on that anytime
you want if they're publishing things
that they know are untrue and their
papers are going to reverse if i take
the time to write to the paper
then for goodness sakes listen to what
i'm saying steve rosenfeld briefly you
find as further evidence of a conspiracy
that a newspaper publishes promptly a
reply to an attack upon you a normal
journalistic purpose
in most cases i think the point is is
that people who bring up the document if
you want something ridiculous try and
take the warren commission report and
relate it to the volumes of evidence i
did
nothing backs it up i even found they
brought somebody in from the pentagon to
write the war commission report that
wasn't even on the investigative staff
and when i went into the minutes the
staff critiques the report line by line
hail boggs and and richard russell and
and uh and john sherman cooper all
wanted to have an alternate report and
warren wouldn't allow it and
you know it you can't take that evidence
and put oswald in the sixth floor window
you can't prove that he owned a gun
or fired a gun that day you can't make
that gun do what was said
by one gun in any way and so you're
you're left with using the evidence that
they present and better evidence that's
come out since the fact that two guns
were firing either either you think that
there were two lone nuts who happen to
show up in dealey plaza on the same day
at the same time with kennedy in mind or
you have a conspiracy now what that
conspiracy is is a deeper question and
it takes more work you don't have to
believe any of us on what we say you
shouldn't go do your homework
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to have a time problem
pretty soon i'd like to get to some of
the questions of people who've been on
their feet ask you to ask brief
questions and i'll try to produce brief
answers um this is a question that has
been alluded to the microphone please
this is a question that's been alluded
to by several of the panelists but i
think if mr rosenfeld could address it
i'd like to know why the press as a
whole has not been as tenacious and
following this kennedy assassination
story as they have been in other stories
and why
they're still afraid to print for
example mark lane's books and articles
okay i'm sorry you didn't identify
yourself and that's one of our ground
rules okay my name is elise and i am a
graduate student here okay
fair criticism of the press for not uh
dogging this story over the years
some
writers have book writers
dan mulday is certainly one of them
perhaps others whom we could name
the
uh
movie it is a reproach to the press
that it took a movie to
blast us all into action again
on this i suppose we didn't do as well
as we should we ought to be more
attentive
i hope in fact i'm confident that you
will find
no conspiracy in this and just routine
laggardness
uh another part of the question is why
mark lane's writings are not given more
attention gee i thought he was a pretty
important figure in the discussion i'm
not a great expert others can advise
we all know his name don't we
his his views are familiar part of the
discussion
thank you next question
hi my name is pamela deters and i'm a
voter and i am very nervous i am
extremely nervous up here but i think
this is important
what i want to know is i listened to the
diane rheem show and i heard john judge
and fletcher prouty on there and you
were talking about a high cabal
what are we talking about here i want
some information i want to know some
specifics
i think let me repeat the question
because some people couldn't hear it
the question said that
she heard the two of you colonel prouty
and mr judge on a radio program here in
washington and that you were talking
about i think she used the term a high
cabal
and she would like you to define this
more specifically and i would add
briefly
well one way to try to do that if it
isn't
already known
i was at the cairo conference in 1943
where churchill roosevelt and chiang
kai-shek met
i was at tehran conference a few days
after that where
churchill roosevelt
and stalin met
well between cairo and tehran i flew the
plane and flew the chinese to that
delegation
but you never hear in any book any
history book any paper any magazine that
i know of that chiang kai-shek was at
tehran
i met elliot roosevelt
enroute there
and
years later i read a book by the man
that
has a job equivalent to chief justice of
the united states
lord denning in
england
and he was speaking of the time of world
war ii and how his friend winston
churchill
would from time to time recall i mean
refer to
a high cabal
and denning's view was my god
in the middle of world war ii
in his position
if there's a cabal higher
than churchill and roosevelt stalin and
chiang kai-shek
it
it's a high cabal but now
if you hear churchill saying that i
think you begin to see what what what
the whole story is i noted among the
chinese that i flew to tehran
were people who were working for tv sung
a [ __ ]
the wealthiest man in the world at the
time
and his wife was married to chiang
kai-shek and his wife went to the
conference she hadn't elected or head of
state or anything like that
april harriman was in moscow
and we all heard what abraham had to say
about world war ii and also about the
vietnam war
there's a high cabal and we better learn
it and understand it and it tells people
how to do things when to do them
it exists
do you mean by that
moneyed interests of like-mind or do you
mean
something on the order of
you know something as
fantastic as you know
a group of men plotting the domination
of the world in just those terms
my boss prulak wrote a book
in which he states
that in pursuit of his assigned duties
he was working on a strategy
for the marines he was a chief marine
pacific at that time
in vietnam
his strategic plan was approved by the
commandant first of all by sync pack in
the pacific admiral sharp
then approved by the commandant on the
marine corps then approved by mcnamara
and mcnamara said but just a minute
before we go to the white house
i want you to
talk with abel harm
he phoned me abraham crew like got
invited to
lunch he briefed his whole plan which
had been approved by all the military
from westmoreland on up to mcnamara
and herrmann said uh
general there's no way we can do that
so the gentleman back to hawaii
he got a call after he arrived there
from general green coming on the marine
corps and he said i have a range for you
to meet with lyndon johnson
flew back witnessing lyndon johnson
and here is a strategic military plan
for forces in vietnam remember it was
the marines that landed there first in
1965 so he was responsible for the
marines operating out
told the whole story to lyndon johnson
lyndon johnson said no we can't do that
so we went back to hawaii
admiral sharp who was syncpac in hawaii
at the time in other words nominally in
charge of all forces in the pacific
has written the book you all like to
read called strategy for defeat
now the military men didn't write that
strategy
i grew up with
general abrams from my hometown the
first man i reported to before pearl
harbor when i came on duty
the greatest
battle commander in world war ii under
patton he was head of the brigade under
patent and later on as you know he was
chief of all forces in vietnam
when he was briefed by johnson and told
to go to vietnam he said
general he said you have 550 000
army troops out there
you've got the best navy in the seventh
fleet and you've got an air force that's
dropping more bombs than we dropped in
world war ii go out there and do it
and general abrams mr president
may i ask your definition of that last
word
go out and do it
what is it you were expecting the
military to do when you got no answer at
all
now that's the kind of thing i'm talking
about because if if the generals weren't
running it
and if dean rusk wasn't running it and
if mcnamara wasn't running it
think
i think that history shows us over a
long time that there are concentrations
of wealth and power first by theft
and then later when we have the
machinery to create wealth
by other design and concentration of
control over resources and over the
politics of situations if it's worth 10
million dollars for the to put the cia
to throw over
a government in a country like chile
then what do you think the elections are
worth here in the united states where
things reside at the at the level that
that the world can be controlled and so
i think that there there isn't one i
don't think you have to think of
conspiracy as a certain group of
individuals a team of five that sit in a
boardroom and call the shot more likely
as in all human affairs there are many
cabals and they compete with one another
and they jockey for positions of power
and they kill one another
and i think that kennedy got in the way
of one that was particularly powerful
at a particular time he had his own
but these concentrations of wealth and
power operate at a level beyond
uh what's up there and with apologies to
senator gonzalez i think that bill
moyer's idea is exactly reversed in the
secret government he says that the
government
congress make a mistake by going out and
hiring these mafia goons and gun runners
and drug carriers and they shouldn't
sully themselves with that and they
should should stick to more honorable
men i think that those
gun runners and opium dealers are the
real government of the united states and
their clandestine intelligence
operatives and that they in turn pay
many people
in three-piece suits to stand up in
front of us and tell us it's the other
way around
next question
my name is paul ruther and i'm here in
my capacity as a tax paying citizen and
voter
i have a brief statement about the movie
and the media's reaction to it and a
question
i was distressed particularly by the
media and of course my own local paper
the washington post treatment of the
movie the movie is called a myth
it it brings untruths to the general
public the government created the myth
that oswald killed the president then
the warren commission is the
documentation of that myth and the
washington post and other media sources
put the myth out
oliver stone presents one myth the
government and the post present another
i fail to see that great of a
distinction except one is art and one is
called journalism
my question is this
which is which as a voter
that's a good question as a voter it
seems to me the least i can do is vote
for someone who wasn't
director of the cia in the next
elections however
[Applause]
i did hear mark lane on the diane reem
show say that george bush was not only
director of the cia but that as far back
as
1963 and even beyond he was a member of
the cia i would like to ask any of the
panelists to confirm what mark lane said
based on what they know and be specific
please anyone anyone here have a
confirmation that george bush
worked for the cia
before he was director of the cia
i never heard that charged and i have i
didn't
wasn't village voice junk it's based
essentially on uh on three three pieces
of evidence so far that i've seen
uh two of them being uh internal
intelligence documents one was an fbi uh
memo that concerned a debriefing by an
fbi agent of a navy intelligence person
in a george herbert walker bush
at the particular address where he lived
in texas and this debriefing was the day
after the kennedy assassination
and and seemed to concern the
anti-castro
uh cuban community in miami
uh and what their reactions would be
there was another document talked about
a george bush of the cia
and and his his relationship to uh
um
turning in another another person i
believe it was a guy named parrot who
was with young americans for freedom and
the young republicans at the time but
there's some some intelligence documents
and then the third area is the relation
between the bay of pigs operation
potentially in bush in that the code
name of the bay pigs was operation
zapata
which is the name of bush's oil company
and two of the ships used in the raid
were the houston where he lived and the
barbara who he married
and
i think we have other indications the
key is when try to get felix rodriguez
to tell you when he met george bush and
you'll get the answer
next question
yeah my name is bill berata i'm from
arlington virginia
and unlike ihara i have to ask you to
get a little closer to them okay
i am from arlington virginia and unlike
e howard hunt and frank sturges i
remember where i was on november 22 1963
and i've got a thousand questions i'd
like to ask one can you just give us one
okay
all right
colonel prouty you say that you think
that the security in dallas that day was
less than adequate or less than normal i
believe
don't you think it's particularly
inadequate in light of the fact that on
november 9th of 1963 the miami police
recorded a conversation with a man named
joseph milteer i believe
wherein he described
the fact that an assassination was in
the works or his word was actually in
the working i've heard the tape
and he also described that the president
would be shot from an office building
with a high-powered rifle
and that
some nut would be picked up to throw
people off
and
one other thing
i can't remember at all but there's just
so much i mean if you need any further
proof of a conspiracy wouldn't that be
it
and why wasn't the warren commission
told about this
i mean the the president kennedy's
appeared on november 18th
in miami four days before he was
assassinated and 11 days after this tape
was
made
and his motorcade was changed he took a
helicopter to speak to the anti-castro
cube oh there's a cuban community
but his motorcade in dallas was not
certainly changed and certainly the
security wasn't beefed up can somebody
comment on that for us please
somebody want to come in
on the conversation taped in miami and
yeah
the acoustics are horrible have you got
an idea well yes um
the
the gentleman is referring to a
conversation that was taped in miami i
believe on november 9 1963
in which
somebody said that the president was
going to be assassinated
joseph
milts here
he appeared before asking me sir it's
only going to be worse without the
microphone so i'll try to i'll try to
represent it as best i can
uh and
the gentleman suggests that this
is further evidence of a conspiracy or
part of the conspiracy and wonders
whether anybody wants to comment on that
on that point
i think there were several plans against
kennedy and miami another one at the
time of the uh
army navy game in october that was that
was pulled back at the last minute when
he had a cold
there were several points miltier of
working with the far right wing i think
was
was privy to some of the details but uh
and and there were different points i
think when you when you do this you do
it with several backup operations i
think that that there's evidence that
there were guns further down stemmons
freeway if the elm street location had
not been a go
but
as mr x says in the movie you leave
nothing to chance
next question
hello my name is michael weintraub and
i'm a freshman in the school of public
affairs and i feel that this
oliver stones movie provides a pretty
valid argument for conspiracy but the
whole basis of that is whether or not
it's a
true movie or if it's just fiction and i
would like to ask colonel crowdy if his
part in the movie as x is true or not or
if it was fiction made up by stone
colonel the question is uh
the the gentleman says that he believes
the movie is convincing but he wants to
know whether it's truth or fiction and
he wants to know whether the part
portraying you as x
is true
or not
or oliver stone's fiction
i'll i'll explain to you
how that was created because the words
the theme the thoughts the whole idea
was in letters not in a personal visit i
happen to have the letters with me
jim garrison had sent me the manuscript
to his book on the trail of the assassin
i read the manuscript
immediately wrote back to jim and that
started and i had known him before this
this started a
exchange of letters
zack schlar the screenwriter
used
the letters and the book in the
development of the script
in addition i had written a series of
articles during the 80s
about vietnam but
elaborating very much on
kennedy and the kennedy assassination
and all that sort of thing
oliver stone heard about him and asked
the editor
of the magazine that they appeared in
for copies of all the magazine he was
sent the copy so oliver stone picked up
material from
magazine work that i wrote
the script
is putting those together
and we wanted to bring the cameras to
washington
because we wouldn't be right to make a
film
john f kennedy without having washington
so the scene between
costner and sutherland
is the screen writers or directors
putting together
material that i can show you they've
been written some of it for years
and i don't think any changes that would
affect its veracity
except the fact they were sitting down
by the vietnam memorial
instead of exchanging letters with each
other
it's a true story except for where they
met
the vietnam memorial of course didn't
exist at that time the vietnam memorial
of course didn't exist at that time well
it certainly did they were filming the
picture in
1991 right and they're just curious
does it disturb you at all that jim
garrison was a shill for the local mafia
in new orleans does that disturb you at
all that he was accepting money from
them and everything else does that
bother you at all
that garrison garrison was accepting
that he was he was a shill for the new
orleans mafia that he was accepting
money from the marcelo organization
does that disturb you at all
and that he is the hero of this film
and that none of this is pointed out at
any point in this film
i can see that
for some people here it needs kind of a
basic explanation
when you look at the hundreds of books
that are available
on the subject of the assassination of
the president
you try to get one
that will bring to the public
a pretty wide view
of the folklore that has developed so
the public will start off on a level
ground
with people who have
called themselves experts in this field
one of the
latest books was
mark's book called
crossfire
stone acquired rights to that book
and another of the latest books was
garrison's book on the trail of the
assassin
using those two books he was able to
present to the public
this stuff we've been hearing all night
here and a lot more about
everything you know the autopsy reports
and all the other things i mean notice
that remember the movie begins with uh
this woman being thrown out of the car
and things like that they're all in the
books
the advantage of using garrison's book
was
that his words and everything he did is
in a court transcript so there's not
much questioning it unless you want to
go back to the court transcript and
match it with his book so it was as good
a base to start with
to bring the public into the film
[Music]
without
too much comment
about what it was because it was just
the folklore could have been 50 other
books
he did use many other books
but primarily those two but colonel
proudly i just to press dan moldy's
question
mr mulday says that jim garrison was
accepting money from mafia figures in
new orleans and that jim garrison's
credibility is compromised on the basis
of his associations
with organized crime figures and he is
asking you whether that bothers you well
that's what he said if you want to
believe it that's right
he was caught with the mark money that
the irs criminal intelligence division
put out i mean he was caught with the
mark money
i mean the evidence is clear on this and
once again it is this this is an
indication of the lack of integrity that
this entire film has where this material
is not dealt with at all in the film
that the principal suspects in this
murder at least according to the house
select me on assassinations
carlos marcel now turns out to have been
the person who owned jim garrison who
had had him on his payroll i think that
should be of some significance to the
people who are actually starting to
believe this paranoid paradise which
oliver stone has put out
next question
uh i'm michael schwartz and i'm playing
hooky to from work to be here tonight
uh-oh uh mr prouty um mr x in the movie
talks about
the overthrow of the democratically
elected government of guatemala were you
present in at the meeting where they
planned to overthrow our benz which led
to one of the worst genocides and one
other thing mr gonzalez will you
continue your attempt to impeach bush
and john judge can you comment on the
bubble top who gave the order to remove
it would it have been bulletproof the
bubble top on the car okay three
questions uh colonel prouty were you
present at the meeting where there was a
the plot was hatched to assassinate
president arbenz of guatemala
uh congressman gonzalez uh will you
continue to uh
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm losing that question
continue to reach george
pressed and moved to impeach george bush
and
and john judge about the bubble top i'd
like to try and get some quickest mr
prouty i want details if you have them
uh
come to the reception uh we're going to
take one more question after this one
and i'd like to get some quick answers
please because we're well over our time
carol patty
as i explained my
years in the pentagon began in 1955.
guatemala was prior to 1955. in 1954 i
was in and out of vietnam flying with
the u.s air force
transport aircraft out of tokyo and into
southeast asia
i did not have anything to do with
guatemala anything else any other
meetings to over to
plan murders or assassinations
you said you discuss it with whoever
wants to know i want to know can can you
get anything out of this
yes the gentleman wants to know if about
other meetings any meetings you attended
where assassinations were discussed he
wants specifics
the assassination of whom of anyone
anybody the assassination of anyone yeah
i'm not going to tell you
he's not going to i know about it but
i'm not going to tell you because you
said you'd tell us
i'm sorry he before he said that he'd
discuss it with whomever wants to know
the gentleman says earlier you said you
would discuss it with anyone who wants
details i want everybody to know and i
want to know true hill
that's enough well mr schwartz uh i did
introduce that um
resolution on january the 15th
of 91
and after a considerable thought
i had been since august attempting to
get the leadership
to address the question of the
president's supra constitutional actions
and on the basis of the resolution
i was hoping i could get some attention
but then the shooting started 12 hours
later and i wasn't about to get any
co-signer on that resolution which i
still haven't however it's consistent
with what i have said and done since
lyndon johnson
i questioned the president's
constitutional authority to conscript an
unwilling american and send him outside
of continental united states without a
declaration of war
that upsets some of the um
so
as far as far as it's uh
possible at this time i think the
question of impeachment would be moot as
far as getting any action all i wanted
was to have a hearing before the
committee and i never did get it
and mr judge the bubble top the decision
to remove the bubble top from the car as
well as to change the route of the
motorcade happened at a private oil club
we don't know which one but we have
reason to believe it was connolly's club
one that he attended it was there were
present an fbi agent unnamed in the
record
a secret service agent by the name of
harold wong and two people from the
advanced public relations firm
um a saul bloom agency where oswald did
some of his photographic work where he
worked at jagger charles stovall because
they had better blow up and reduction
equipment over at the ad agency than the
than the contractor did
uh their names were jack pewterbaugh and
elizabeth forsling she later married
leon harris
uh the uh the guy that ran the
department stores there in dallas and
big money she was referred to
in uh in those years as a dallas contact
by the washington intelligence community
she later found co-founded ms magazine
with another ci agent by the name of
gloria steinem
uh there's not an attack on feminism on
my part i believe in radical feminism
but people have histories and should be
should be looked at and she was the one
that specifically brought up
leaving the bubble top off the car
there was a conversation between
uh
that proudly mentioned the radio between
lbj and hoover where hoover said the
bubble top wouldn't have made any
difference but i think anything that
would have deflected a shot would have
had a significance to a gunman what
about the popular story about jfk
ordering the removal because he wanted
to be a popular uh president in close
touch with the people is that you know
anything about that congressman gonzalez
you were there do you mean yes i think
we ought to understand something here mr
judge
i happen to be there the morning after
the breakfast at the hotel
in fort worth it had been raining
when we took our place to leave the
hotel to go back to carswell air force
base where we were going to fly 10
minutes over to love field
the
presidential car was right
in front of us
to my surprise the sun came out
and i noticed and i commented to those
that were with me look at this and i
noticed the bubble top
emerging up you know pulling back like a
convertible car so i don't know that it
was removed i think it was a type of car
that had the capability
the reason you didn't have the bubble
top was because
the weather was no longer inclement by
the time the parade in dallas however
there was one thing that was unusual
i've never been in any kind of a parade
of that kind
where the average speed was no less than
30 miles an hour down the main street in
dallas
it was very unusual but
i don't think we should consider that
the bubble top was removed because there
was some sinister i think
it was part of the fact that it wasn't
raining any longer had it been raining
the bubble top would have been there
that is what is called a disarmingly
simple explanation
those of us that worked in protection
elizabeth harris
the secret service did not have a bubble
top that was effectively stopped bullets
nor did they have one single armored car
fbi adam not secret service in 1963. we
knew that in a pentagon
next
question
my name is cynthia johnson i work with
women strike for peace here in
washington d.c
i wonder if anyone here can comment on
the connection between the cns
committee for national security the
american bar association the institute
of peace and
the aba the american bar
association
i've heard there are some connections
and
as pat dowell so aptly said we are
concerned with our government now and i
i really this is a very sincere question
i hope you won't take it as naive
but right now in the last months i've
been very concerned about well one of
the cover stories and since we're
dealing with secrecy and democracy in
government our hope for democracy right
now in washington or in the last days in
washington the oas with our executive
branch has been negotiating for the
constitutional return of the president
of haiti
now most haitian people believe that
this is a sham
because
our government is not that the u.s
ambassador in haiti is the person who is
running that country now he is an
alumnus of the phoenix program in
vietnam and i very sincerely want to ask
people like colonel prouty and
congressman gonzalez and mr judge how
can it happen if this is at all true how
does a u.s ambassador what kind of
activities are going on that even a
people in a sovereign country can
believe that their country is being run
by the u.s ambassador and that
negotiations that our executive branch
is supporting for
democracy are just a sham i i i'll try
to allow some
brief comments on i do i think the
question is a little bit far from our
subject it isn't because we're talking
about the 1963 and covert activities yes
i understand but you're standing there
and i'm sitting here we have to try and
bring the program to a conclusion i'm
sorry i
but does somebody have
something to
say about the negotiations relating
to the return of president aristide to
haiti or the or haiti being run by the
american ambassador
and i'm sorry i didn't catch the thing
about the american bar association um
maybe at the reception afterwards we
could deal with some of those questions
let me take one last question
well
i'm sarah cutler and i'm an educator and
i am i'm an educator
and i've been following the super
constitutional the process of going to
war
and when the president said he didn't
have to go to congress for this last war
i've been following the legal advice and
i've been reading the articles in the
various newspapers and contacting those
lawyers which led me to the american bar
association
committee for national security which is
very small
and it was started by somebody on the
committee on the present danger which
was originally started by an admiral in
1950
then i heard about the committee again
in 1974 but i didn't hear anything about
that committee in the 60s
i expressed
at the aba meetings
i found out about the u.s institute of
peace because some of those people were
there
which brought me to their meetings
and um there is an interlocking board
between those through three groups
i'm sorry and there is i i'm i really
don't want to cut you off but this is
well beyond the subject of our forum
tonight and i'll have to ask you to
discuss this with the panelists at the
reception afterwards you want to do it i
i
i think that we have held on to a very
loyal committed devoted audience and i
appreciate all of you for being here i'm
sorry we can't get to all the questions
there is a reception on the first floor
of mary graydon center before we go
there
let me say a couple things with such a
large audience in the hall we will have
additional forums in the american forum
series on tuesday february 11th monday
march 2nd and wednesday april 1st in
this room
if you would like to be on our mailing
list there are cards outside the doors
so that you can get on the mailing list
and be informed about the forums i want
to thank once again the people who have
made these forms possible the xerox
foundation the washington gas light
company
[Music]
[Applause]
the xerox foundation the washington gas
light company cable holdings and the
evelyn y davis foundation and i want to
thank fletcher prouty stephen rosenfeld
pat dowell
henry gonzalez john judge and dan mulday
for being with us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
for more information on this american
forum you can write to the american
university school of communication at
4400 massachusetts avenue northwest here
in washington dc
the zip code is 20016
or for a transcript of this event send
ten dollars to c-span transcripts in
care of tape writer incorporated post
office box 885 in lincolnshire illinois
the zip code is 60069.
are you going to join us
good please do
is it in this building
[Music]
how did you guys
[Music]